hey everyone welcome back to another
video by simply learn in this video we
will understand how to make YouTube
videos stand out with chat gbt Chad gbt
is like a helpful assistant that guides
you in making catchy titles descriptions
and tags for your videos chat gbt can
also help you come up with interesting
scripts and Designs eye-catching
thumbnails Etc it understands how
YouTube works making it easier for your
videos to get noticed so in this video
we will understand what is YouTube SEO
and why is it important key elements of
YouTube SEO the role of tags in YouTube
SEO and at last we will understand how
to use chat gbt for YouTube SEO which
includes writing descriptions tags and
titles in just one click with the help
of Hands-On examples that is demo so
let's understand first topic which is
what is YouTube SEO and why is it
important so YouTube SEO or search
engine optimization is the process of
optimizing your YouTube videos to rank
higher in search results and gain more
visibility it involves using relevant
keywords creating compelling video
titles descriptions and tags and
encouraging user engagement YouTube SEO
is crucial because it helps your videos
get discovered by wider audience did you
know that 70% of what people watch on
YouTube is determined by its
recommendation algorithm the Staggering
statistic highlights the significance of
optimizing your content content to align
with the YouTube's algorithms when
people search for content on YouTube the
platform uses an algorithm to determine
which videos to show by optimizing your
videos you increase the chances of your
content appearing in search results and
suggested videos attracting more viewers
by incorporating an optimal number of
tags in your videos typically ranging
between 31 and 40 you can boost views up
to by
89% ultimately effective YouTube SEO can
boost your vide visibility increase
organic traffic and help you grow your
channel by reaching a larger audience
furthermore YouTube SEO involves
understanding viewer behavior and
creating content that keeps audience
engaged factors like watch time click-
through rate and user interaction impact
how YouTube Ranks videos to enhance SEO
consider creating compelling thumbnails
and crafting engaging video
introductions consistency in uploading
content and building a loyal subscriber
base also play pivotal roles now just a
quick info for you if you want to
upskill yourself master digital
marketing skills and land your dream job
or grow in your career then you must
explore simply Lear Cort through various
digital marketing programs simply run
offers various certification and
post-graduate programs in collaboration
with some of the world's leading
universities like spj and Purdue and
meta through our courses you will gain
knowledge and work R your expertise in
skills like search engine marketing
strategies for paid campaigns analytics
Roi and evaluation and over a dozen of
others that's not all you'll also get
the opportunity to work on multiple
projects and learn from the industry
experts working in Top Tire product
companies and academian from top
universities after completing these
courses thousands of Learners have
transitioned into digital marketing role
as a fresher or moved onto a Higher ping
job and profile if you are passionate
about making your career in this field
then make sure to check out the link in
the pin comments and description box to
find digital marketing program that fits
your experience in areas of Interest now
let's have a look at the overview of key
elements of YouTube Su so key elements
like video titles descriptions tags and
thumbnails are critical components of
effective YouTube content
optimization so let's understand these
first video titles a video title is like
a headline it should be attention
grabbing and contain relevant keywords
to help both viewers and YouTube
algorithm understand the video's content
a well-crafted title can significantly
impact whether users decide side to
click and watch the next is description
so the video description is an
opportunity to provide more details
about your content include relevant
keywords naturally add links to related
content or external sites and use the
description to engage with your audience
YouTube often looks at the section to
understand the context of your video all
right now the third one is tags tags are
like labels that help categorize your
video they consist of keywords related
to your content
using accurate and popular tags can
increase the likelihood of your video
appearing in search results and
recommended video lists then the last
one is thumbnails thumbnails also play a
very important role thumbnails are the
visual representation of your video a
compelling thumbnail can attract
attention prompting users to click on
your video use clear and high quality
images and consider adding text that
hints at the videos content thumbnails
play a crucial role in The Click through
trate by optimizing these key elements
ments Creator increases the chances of
their videos being discovered and
clicked on by a broader audience so this
was about the key elements of YouTube
SEO now let's understand the role of
tags in YouTube SEO so in YouTube SEO
tags play a crucial role in enhancing a
video's discoverability and reach tags
are essential descriptive keywords that
you associate with your video content
here is how they contribute to
optimizing your videos first is
categorization and content text tags
help YouTu categorize and understand the
context of your video when users search
for Content or when the algorithm
suggest videos it relies on tags to
identify and recommend videos that are
relevant to the user's query and second
is search engine ranking tags contribute
to your video's position in YouTube
search results using relevant and
specific tags increase the likelihood of
your video appearing when users searches
for Content related to your text all
right now the third one is related video
recommendations YouTube uses tags to
determine which videos are related to
each other well choosen tags can lead to
your video being suggested to viewers
watching content similar to yours this
expands the potential audience for your
videos the next is optimizing for Trends
and topics tags can be adjusted to align
with current trends or popular topics
this can help your video write the wave
of trending searches making it more
likely to be seen by a larger audience
so this was about the rules of tags in
YouTube SEO so now let's understand
practically how to use chat gbt for
YouTube SEO all right so first of all
let's navigate to Google and search for
aipm so this is the first link that will
appear all we have to do is just click
on that visit this link and as you can
see it is an extension so aipm for chat
GPD is an extension so you will have to
click on this add to Chrome ADD
extension all
right so as you can see chat GPT
is is opening and this is what we can
see human written 100% unique as
optimized article so this is basically
AI PRM extension that helps us do all
these tasks they are pre-written prompts
and we can use these prompts to write
whatsoever we want we can also select
from these topics what we can do what we
want to do like copyright devops
generative AI marketing Etc activity
ideation keywords link building
marketing Etc
Outreach then we can also sort it by top
votes trending model not specific we can
use all of these so basically they are
pre-written prompts so you don't have to
write the complete prompt over here you
can also select from these prompts and
as you can see there are a lot of
prompts one showing 1 to 12 there are
total 1,5 prompts so we can also
navigate from previous and next all
right so now what we can do is basically
we'll have to do a YouTube suo using
chat GPT so first of all we can select
SEO usually it is on by default it is on
all we can select SEO first of all now
uh we'll go to
search wait a minute you can go to
keywords as well now we can select
search and we can type
YouTube seu all right so these all
prompts are appearing so this prompt has
370k so this means 370k people have seen
this or you use this then there is
YouTube SEO template 4.2k YouTube SEO
keyword template 3.9k so we basically
want to use this one only because this
prompt this pre-written prompt is
providing us create 15 SEO clickbait
YouTube titles so it will give us 15
clickbait titles for YouTube YouTube
YouTube description it will write
YouTube tags it will provide and YouTube
hashtags as well so there are pretty
more as well as you can see in just one
click all right so we basically will
click on this and select so this prompt
is basically have selected so now all we
have to do is write the seed keyword or
write the keyword on which we want to do
YouTube SEO so let's say the seed G is
MBA
in
MBA in
USA so let's see what this will
create all
right beginning middle and end all right
so it is also telling us the best title
to pick from all these that is beginning
middle and end so mastering MBA in USA
Insider tips and tricks all right so
this title combines Authority mastering
relevance MBA in USA and Intrigue ins
Ider tips and tricks making it
compelling and likely to track clicks so
it is also telling us how they are
selecting this title as the best title
so they have written that this title
combines Authority relevance and the
Intrigue Insider tips and tricks making
it comparing and likely to track clicks
all right and this is also YouTube
description as they have written in the
prompt so welcome to ultimate guide on
achieving an MBA in USA in this
comprehensive video we will delve deep
into strategy Secrets how professionally
they have written this description we
can see and don't miss out the insights
that can transform your dreams into
reality subscribe now for more valuable
content on educational persuades and
career growth so they have written a
perfect description that will also
contain all the relevant keywords so
that the videos get ranked and when it
comes to hashtags as we can see MBA in
USA success strategies mastering MBA
Career Development USA study guide
Insider tips future leadership Etc all
right so this was about the hashtags and
now let's come to the tags that is the
important part also MBA in USA success
strategies they have separated each of
the tags with comma so you can use and
select on your own whichever you want to
select so they have written quite a few
of tags you can select from these all so
they have provided us tags hashtags best
title pick to pick and we can also
select from these as per our choice but
they have basically created a best title
from all of these and these are the
descriptions that we can use so what
else do we need to do YouTube suo so you
can just take a help from this extension
of chat GPT and you can use and do the
YouTube SEO using the chat gbt all right
so let's do another one all right so new
chat let's do again SEO keywords you can
select YouTube SE all right so again
we'll click on this prompt YouTube SE
typ title description with text
generator so this is basically giving us
all of these things that we want and
let's write this time the seed keyword
would be let's say cat
preparation let's
see so beginning keywords I mean
beginning title middle and end so best
title is your success awaits dive into
effective cat preparation this title not
only promises success but also
encourages immediate action making it
compelling for viewers so this is the
description welcome to transformative
journey in cat preparation in this video
we will delve into the effective
strategies to boost your scores and
elevate your skills all right so these
are the hashtags cat preparation success
mastering cat exam tips cat preparation
strategies Etc these are the hashtags
that we can use and these are again the
tags so we can select the tags as per
our choice what all things we are
covering and what all things we want to
include in our video so we can take a
help of this extension of chat gbt and
do our YouTube SEO so this is how you
can do YouTube SEO using the chat GPT
all right guys if you like this video
please give it a thumbs up I hope it
really helped you all thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upscaling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
program s and set yourself on the path
to Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here